we don't mean to be disrespectful to the
president but I have gotten and as did
my co-author my daughter lives we feel
very very strongly that were headed in
the wrong direction this administration
is taking us exactly the opposite
direction from which we ought to be a
turd the President did not want to have
I don't believe any stay behind for us
in Iraq I don't think it was consistent
with the campaign he he drowned when he
campaigned against our forces in Iraq
and promised to bring them all out
during the course of the campaign and I
don't think he wanted an agreement it
was not a flawless war but I've never
seen one that was I don't hesitate to
defend what we did and with respect to
whether or not that we did the right
thing going into Iraq I believe it I
know we argue about it different people
have different views the president has
consistently as consistently refused to
recognize or to admit that there is a
huge problem out there with respect to
the proliferation of terror and it's I
think when you see what's happening in
Iraq you've got part of that is a
refusal to recognize the nature of the
problem that we're faced with which is
more serious than just Iraq